mais bon on the floor construire un
chemin à bombay dolan anne jeanson
marine basé au mans
dans les membres juan constants
ballan it basé à steam
je voulais vous informer que je suis
positif pour le couronner un virus j'ai
eu de la fièvre y hier mon texte initial
s'est avéré le positif tard dans la
soirée
je me suis isolé dans un endroit depuis
hier soir soyez assurés que nous
vaincrons le coronavirus soyez certains
que nous le ferons j'y crois de tout mon
coeur prenez soin de vous ce virus est
un virus démocratique
il ne fait pas de distinction entre les
riches et les pauvres ou autres
fonctionnaires et nos fonctionnaires
tout le monde peut la voir alors que le
président iranien annonce mardi que
l'iran surmonterait l'épidémie un membre
du parlement vient d'annoncer sur
twitter être également infectée par le
virus
[Musique]